Amazon released a web service called
Mechanical Turk which is basically a
labor distribution tool so Amazon
basically says here's thousands of
workers coming online to do simple tasks
and now you can pay them a very small
fee and have them do anything for you
and they open the API to developers and
I was thinking well what would happen if
we use these people who are creative
tasks and kind of embrace the fact that
they're actually people behind these
terminals and I started off by taking
frames from Charlie Chaplin's modern
times which is kind of about the last
changes in the labor systems so I took a
frame where Charlie Chaplin's being
pushed through gears physically and I
took one frame segmented into 16 pieces
and I fed those pieces in the Mechanical
Turk with a custom drawing tool that I
created and said basically draw what you
see and nobody has any idea what it is
that they're creating but in the end
they're all working together to create
this animation of Charlie Chaplin's body
being pushed through these gears so
these people did amazing jobs I think
particularly because it was a creative
task because they were kind of embracing
the fact that they you know this was
something unique and kind of fun
so from there I kind of began thinking
about what other things can can I do and
I started thinking about metaphors in
kind of the ways that I see the system
or at least ways that I could with more
than a hint of irony kind of get people
thinking about what this type of system
means so I used Mechanical Turk and set
up a very simple request I said draw
sheep facing to the left and I'll pay
two cents for your toil so I chose sheep
for a variety of reasons first of all
selectively bred and then kind of
harvested using them for their wool and
for other other things and of course
then of course cloning and I created a
little drawing tool and pointed them to
it and I actually recorded the process
of them drawing sheep in addition to the
drawing itself people didn't actually
realize that they were being monitored
if they had no idea why they were
drawing a sheep but for some reason
10,000 people contributed their sheep
and now at the Sheep market calm you can
see every single sheep and how it was
drawn and you can watch the animation
process this
kind of a sample of those which ended up
being printed on collectable stamps
obviously I wanted to create a website
and I wanted to put it back online in
the form that I think it closely matches
which is this online exhibition and
allowing it to be reached by the masses
seeing as that was created by the masses
but I also wanted to create kind of an
installation where a viewer could kind
of be physically engaged with it and
kind of be surrounded by the Sheep so
that that's what made me print out print
out all the stamps and actually hang
them on the wall in this gigantic matrix
and I think what I really liked about
that format was that it really shows
this structured system when you when
you're back looking at it looks like
some kind of weird barcode like weird
computerized thing and as you get closer
to it you realize that it's actually
extremely kind of organic personal data
that's being clustered into the system
and when you juxtapose that kind of
intimate process with this huge kind of
computer bureaucratized
grid like barcode system I think you get
some kind of interesting I get some
interesting revelations from